Ciao amici allora questo è un video
Allora allora eh Benvenuti ragazzi
a questo Roma Lombardo che è comunque un
posto che esiste ce la sono Lombardo con
i ragazzi pantera ormai Ciao ciao Hai
vinto Luca a fare nel mio canale che io
stesso eh fisco partecipazione extra
questa ragazzi è Everybody one two
switch il gioco per cui sono andato in
Giappone una seconda volta e loro sono
contenti per questo sì questo magico
gioco ti gioca con più persone quindi io
ho chiamato i miei amici Il mio misto
grazie Allora qua sono dei icone Io sono
un formaggio io voglio essere l'ananas
Bravo Ah Formiamo le squadre io e J
faremo capire che che ne sappiamo
veramente bravi Allora questi sono i
giochi disponibili Io faccio schifo in
tutti quanti quindi non c'è niente
tranne in questo allora spiega Jack come
sapete cos'è allora lui ti fa vedere un
timer Ok tu devi contare esattamente
fino a 10 e poi gira a fare questo
questo movimento Ok dopo un po' sparisce
il timer attenzione conta
Quanto è costato male cioè un'ora prima
immaginato c'è un'ora prima
Brava brava No secondo me stavolta non
era male
No io ci ho messo mezz'ora dai
Ragazzi
ma deve uscire no no noi siamo
Spadaccini e vuoi uscire giriamo verso
di loro lo faccio Guarda come lo faccio
io Guarda eh
Ma porca
ma come hai fatto adesso gli dobbiamo
uscire
posso stare qua in mezzo Dai come faccio
così non vedo niente
i problemi di Paul Stevenson si palesano
Durante l'infanzia ma a 45 anni i suoi
tic peggiorano
no mi ha ucciso Luis
abbiamo vinto abbiamo vinto C'era finale
ninja con la Katana
sta già giocando
Bravo Bravo bravo
bravissimo bravissimo
ma è impossibile
Alex techted
i palloncini
in alto concentrati sull'alto non deve
andare oltre quello Boh basta fine non
c'è niente Quindi dobbiamo fermarci ci
sei
[Musica]
si comincia piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano piano
Noi ci siamo giuro forse un po' più
grosso Non lo so Oh
ce l'ho ancora uno bravino 100%
[Applauso]
no raga no Sì sì
è fortissima che sono Bravo bravo
bravissimo bellissimo
bellissimo
così
via No no 1 2 3 3 1
per l'inferno
No
non si fanno queste cose nei giochi
moderni uhm uhm
due due tre cinque minuti voglio raga
Guarda che questa figura di merda
bravo ma ero fermo ero fermo e squid
game
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Complimenti Complimenti
[Musica]
girerà questo ragazzino e adesso ragazzi
facciamo minigioco con gli smartphone
perché possiamo utilizzare quelli invece
che i joy-con mettendo le nostre
bellissime facce
quiz Show cultura generale che siete
bravi voi perché io non sono bravo credo
che lui ti faccia delle domande di
cultura generale veloce di
tutti perché devi essere veloce Tenute
di sbagliare
Sasso perché le forbici ovviamente
perdono con il sasso Ragazzi ma la mia
risposta non è stata questa
io ho sbagliato come faccio e ci ho
messo un'ora di cammino cioè io ho
sbagliato e non solo non lo caccio messo
un'ora a capirlo No dai Magari non me la
sento uno strumento bellissimo a fianco
Ok è cambiato
il diploma ragazzi
Ma com'è possibile sbagliato tutte e
come ultimo gioco Ragazzi abbiamo scelto
ufo che è il preferito quasi di tutti
credono Allora
in questa finale che poi se perdiamo un
casino
vai
Bravo bravo
bravo
adesso adesso a sinistra
bravissima cioè amore
sei pulenta Ti potrei chiedere Occhio al
ritmo
sì
Sì questo comunque è il gioco cioè tra
tutti e il migliore non c'è niente da
fare pubblico sia fortissimo bellissimo
siamo uguali tra l'altro 92 finiscono 0%
Ok ragazzi lei non lo sa ma le avevo
spento il Joy con Ma questo lo saprà
soltanto quando il video verrà
pubblicato
di oggi che sanno quello che fanno
Ragazzi ci vediamo ad un prossimo video
ringrazio iPantellas come si fanno le
auto nel 2023 sono un saluto con degli
amo io questo non lo faccio Ci vediamo
al prossimo video Un bacio Un saluto
agli altri
no raga aspetta si è Stoppato tutto lì
vabbè